[Music]
sup guys and PhD here so we're
approaching the end of the year but it's
still tech Tober and one of my favorite
phones of this year 2019 was the oneplus
7 pro so I guess oneplus felt the need
to update their lineup right for the
holiday season so they did and our
newest phone is this the oneplus 7t pro
now a lot of you guys have been asking
me how I feel about this phone it might
be the smallest incremental update from
phone to phone that I've ever seen so if
I put these phones right next to each
other you might not know which one is
which on the left is the 1 + 7 Pro and
on the right is a 1 plus 70 Pro but if
you couldn't tell just by that glance
allow me to show you all of the
differences so on the back we have a
slightly new color it's still blue but
instead of nebula blue it's what they
call haze blue you know it's a little
bit lighter honestly I like it a little
bit less it's a bit fingerprint tea and
it's also less matte but hey at least
now you know which one is which this is
haze blue and you can see the oneplus 70
Pro has a laser autofocus cut out next
to the camera module which looks like an
addition but that may just be a bit of a
psychological trick because the 7 Pro
already had a laser autofocus module
built into the camera module in between
the cameras there so this isn't a new
sensor or anything they just moved it to
the outside of the module and now it
looks like a new one anyway then on the
inside you're looking at snapdragon 855
+ + 8 gigabytes of ram and 256 as the
only speck so there's no 12 gig option
in the regular one + 70 Pro anymore but
the new processor is a little bump and
then the battery situation technically
also got an upgrade you're now looking
at a very slightly larger 4000 85
milliamp hour battery and that's coming
from the four thousand milliamp hour
battery we already had in the oneplus 7
pro do we even count that as an upgrade
technically yeah I mean it's not smaller
so I guess we should be happy about that
but yeah slightly just very slightly
larger sure the real upgrade here is the
slightly faster warp charge 30 T and
package that's the same size so the
charger comes in the box it supports 23%
faster charging because of the new
battery tech it's already an extremely
fast charger I do appreciate that
cameras I I'd say same triple cameras I
believe the exact same three sensors but
with the added macro mode which is a
hardware adjustment they added a little
motor to the main camera that lets you
get super super close for minimum focus
distance in a macro mode same thing we
saw on the 70 it's pretty cool lets you
get super close to subjects if you're
into macro photography on your phone and
that's it that's all that's new for the
70 pro the rest in case you forgot is
basically the same as they already
excellent 7 pro same 6 point 6 7 inch
1440p 90 hertz oled notch list display
one my favorites of the year same pop up
camera mechanism to achieve that
Nautilus design same super fast ufs 3.0
storage these are all pretty much things
i loved about that 1 plus 7 pro the
thing I dislike the most was the curved
edges on the screen but I'm not shocked
that they didn't change that yet I'll
hold out hope for next version so
there's no all new cameras to bring it
up to compete with the pixel there's no
5g version there's no wireless charging
there's no major features added to the 7
T Pro it's just basically a little bit
of a tweak to their already great phone
to bring it up to the end of 2019
standards tech moves fast I get it so
that's this is the latest and greatest
if you already have their latest phone
obviously you don't have to upgrade but
this is their greatest available option
but of course we can't forget to include
the McLaren Edition that they also
introduced next to it so this is the
oneplus 70 Pro McLaren Edition a pretty
long name with a bit of a different
design for a hundred extra bucks this is
going to be your dramatic dark forged
carbon fiber looking design and papaya
orange accents that McLaren is famous
for I think it looks pretty badass but
it's also a huge fingerprint magnet with
this glossy finish so I kind of wish it
was sort of a hybrid of like a frosted
glass version of this may be a little
more matte to get this this crazy carbon
fiber look to
through but not attract finger prints
but just the way it is it really catches
the light a certain way and you can see
more and more of the carbon pattern
under the glass very cool and I think
people who appreciate supercars will
really appreciate this one and the
McLaren Edition is available with 12
gigs of RAM so that is the only spec
difference if you're looking for a
reason for the McLaren Edition to be
faster which they've done in the past
that's the only thing 12 gigs of ram on
the McLaren Edition eight gigs of RAM on
the regular phone that's it so they have
it you know you guys wanted me to cover
it and now we have our hands on it and
it's like I said maybe the smallest
upgrade I've ever seen in a phone which
I guess makes sense with the t version -
a phone that came out just eight months
ago of course the point is it's a slight
upgrade from what was already the
fastest phone I've ever used and was one
of my favorites so you know a little
tweaks here and there just increase the
lead a little bit on one of the best
smartphone experiences of 2019 for me
with this new one the strangest thing
about this phone might be their decision
not to bring it to North America they're
not selling it in the US they're not
continuing their push with higher priced
phones in this expensive market putting
in carrier stores and things like that
they chose not to do that with this
phone so special thanks to South from
super staff TV he is the only reason I
got to check out these phones he brought
them over here with him so I'm gonna
have to give it right back to him big
shout-out to super staff I'll have a
link to his channel below so I guess I'm
not mad you know I already have a 1 + 7
Pro it's in the u.s. it's basically the
same thing and I can live without the
slightly faster charging and the new
chip and macro mode I guess
I'll live with that but as hope to
Franco would say I'm gonna pass the
question off to you have you ever seen a
one to one upgrade this small in
smartphones before you don't have to
answer that it's probably no I guess
basically oneplus wanted to have
something available right around October
October for the holiday season they got
it out you can get it in certain markets
if you don't you can get a one plus
seven Pro that's mainly the gist there
you have it I've covered it we're out
here tech tober rolls on thanks for
watching this one gadget has the next
one pace